[Music]
in bad parenting news Oh Florida hmm
submitted by salty pig nips salty pig
nip okay yeah is that a thing I'm
looking I mean
you pork rinds is a thing it's just
fried pig skin so I don't know they
probably got some nips in there
somewhere that sounds good spicy pork
rinds they're good I love the spicy ones
hot and spicy bad mm-hmm that was some
cold-ass beer that's my [ __ ]
the Internet is outrage at a video of a
nine-year-old getting a tattoo with his
mom's consent oh [ __ ]
oh it's probably bad huh like it's done
bad it's a pretty bad touch
see I'd be more mad at the artwork then
like if it was a dope I'll be like no
the dumb thing is is that he's nine
years old as an adult that's why you
just gotta get a spider with legs
extended so that they just stretch think
about a bird that gets its bigger there
you go bigger smile it could be like a
really hot girl and then when he gets
old she's like really big if she ages
with him oh yes she puts on the freshman
15 with him yeah so this took place in
Ohio
hey what up there you go are you from
Ohio Ohio
wait what city in Ohio Lido
they just said Ohio
Oh Bella Fontaine I don't know one of
those cities I don't never heard of so
this kid was getting tatted up by a 16
year old Holly what is going on right
with the mom the mom was filming the
video oh no now we show you guys the
video what's the mom 16 I don't know
okay this will be the course Canada
school though oh for sure oh man and in
the month
why is everybody naked in there yeah why
it's just a tattoo place this kid is
gonna grow to be a dumbass I already
tell just by the way stop well look at
her look at his brother okay he wanted
it he wanted to drive the car if that
was the mom she looks like about 17
that's not the mom the mom was filming
oh oh okay cuz her shirt said mom so I
was just like oh wow what is that a
snake yes I don't even know kids arms
look like a Vienna sausage huh yeah yeah
what is that is that a snake with the s
or just a s that's not even a right
cursive s yeah I have no idea what the
hell this is but it's on a nine year old
okay you know it doesn't surprise me
though there's not much to do you know
hi Oh as long as you guys figure things
out you know would you do burn things
down I mean we would I mean we'd be the
dumbest stuff like we wouldn't got at
Walmart like that's where this sounds
really great yeah that sounds like so we
didn't close Walmart this is actually
from long yes so that we when we're
when we were like you know there's like
a time right where you're not quite able
to smoke or drink or whatever yet so
everyone just kind of hangs out at
shopping malls or like outside of like
outlet stores not at 9:00 we used to do
like games and so yeah yeah hell yeah
yeah nine nine we were like inventing
board games and playing with each other
nine you know what I liked I was always
out doing stupid doing stuff yeah the
best thing about being that age around
like seven eight nine is when you would
get into fistfights you'll find the next
day we just because the type of people
you're fighting have Vienna sausage arms
was strong so we just get socked in the
face or whatever just started to get
scrapes and stuff but if no one knows
how to fight and at that age
everyone's doing this yeah and at that
age there the concept that there's
nothing to do hasn't entered your mind
yet because you look at everything and
like you can make a game out of it I'm a
tree you can do like yeah yeah it's like
I'll race you to that tree exactly do
you do that
where's now it's like hey Joe will you
raise me that tree you're like no I'm
tired bro like I just I get tired
thinking about that unless it's like
you're in the right mindset you're like
oh I'm doing a Spartan Race like you're
drunk oh you could I mean both of them
they bring you to that mindset I
remember like being that age in like the
world was my playground and everything
was like a good idea
nothing was a bad idea what has changed
reality I think what would change now is
like you go oh but I could get hurt
oh I still feel like you're like the
world's my playground and it's but then
now I'm like thinking things like oh but
that's illegal
oh yeah but it'll cost money I have such
a naysayer of my head yeah like the
consequences in your head yeah I just
don't want to die so I'm like I don't
wanna go skydiving I could die yeah I
don't want to like drive fast I could
die you're a little you know now now
whereas we're not little I don't give a
clock I'm like yeah let's go fast I want
I want that waterfall in Pali that was
cool he wasn't going to he was like no
[ __ ] way I'm gonna do have you they
have you just slide off of it like it
was a huge water it's a waterfall and
there's rocks down there no there's not
rocks that there's technically rocks
like down there down there rocks on the
earth yeah yeah yeah basically you just
kind of like Oh fine dude lay on the
rock and scoot off and we did that [ __ ]
on what's it well we like to Maui that
one that one died oh yeah there's a
couple it was cliff jumping oh yeah oh
yeah I'm talking about sliding down a
natural water slide in a waterfall
that's cool it was really cool it was so
cool it was scary as [ __ ] because you
just don't know what's under you yeah
how high was it 25 feet oh wow did you I
did someone say I didn't think I could
do it either but then my wife did it I
couldn't be a [ __ ] I heard it someone
did you go in the water first and then
kind of swim around it and go I could do
it we did some cliff jumping first well
because the guide the tour guys are all
this [ __ ] tall dude they're like
they're like little guys right and so
I'm like I couldn't do this and they're
like oh no you'll be okay and I'm like
well my feet will probably hit the
bottom and they're like yeah doing this
[ __ ] no way so because you know like
what we're next to stuff right and they
go why are you so scared there's a rail
there yeah cuz the rail is literally
below my dick it doesn't do anything you
[ __ ] five-foot-three [ __ ] like what
are you talking about well also the more
you do it the less scarier it becomes
yeah yeah like if you keep cliff diving
then it's kind of like all this is like
walking now and now you didn't yeah and
you the next thing that challenges you
but then I enjoy it for the first
initial scare but then later it just
feels like working out mmm tubing yeah
like in the very beginning it's like yay
right and then if you do it like the
fifth or sixth I then I'm like I'm tired
of climbing back up and jump in now I
would do it again and again for the
waterslide one though Oh
I fell sick I did it twice it was so fun
if you're a kid would tell you that they
wanted to tattoo
no hell no when you're old enough yeah I
mean 80 I have no control of you I would
I would not love it I'd be like I'd
express my disdain for it but do you
guys have to know I feel like the
technology is gonna be so damn good in
the future that people could just get it
out
I just want my kid to get one after
they've experienced enough life exactly
it's like look you've experienced your
[ __ ] now now little stuff that you get
with it yeah you know cuz I have some
shady ass taste when also plus you don't
know at that age what kind of job you're
gonna like to do you know like and it
might impede your future work if you
already got set as an artist or like you
work for yourself or whatever yeah if I
can get a tattoo like your double
advocate though just I'm not saying I
can do this
always but isn't this kid gonna learn
from his mistake the hard way good thing
permanent but it's not his mistake it's
his mom's yeah but he has to carry maybe
he is his mouse mistake oh sorry no I
didn't mean that the biggest mistake you
say he's a walking talking four foot
eleven tattoo Wow
the biggest mistake is how shitty that
tattoo is that's true it's the the two
artists at 16 a 16 year old student that
was like a sick transformer I'd be like
whoo look good see that's that's my
thing is like I feel like the younger
you are the shitty or your tastes are
because you haven't seen the world and
you don't have that much money so you do
things on a bargain
you can't [ __ ] pay top dollar for the
best artist to do [ __ ] so so for me I'm
like well if you're young but you have a
good taste and you know your [ __ ] art
do it something that's always gonna be
tight right like if you get like [ __ ]
I remember kids watching the Thundercats
and nowadays if I was like you're I'm
when you wash Thundercats didn't you
shut the [ __ ] up dude I don't tell
people I watch Thundercats yeah right
but like if you get something sick where
it's like I'm getting Godzilla on my arm
it's like no matter what Godzilla on
your arm is pretty sick it's pretty
thick there's only
two options I have as a parent it's like
number one tell them hey wait until
you're older and you have good choices
or number two I'm just gonna plant the
dumbest tattoo ideas in his head hey
every girl for that you get tattoo their
name on you make fun of them yeah so
this mom she was arrested and charged
with first-degree misdemeanor child
endangering and contributing to the
delinquency of a minor it sounds about
right
yeah her name is Nikki she's 34 years
old and this is her mug shot
she dirty [ __ ] she said that she
finally let her kid get it because she
was tired of hearing him well you're a
terrible parent no hearing him say that
he wanted to get a tattoo so she was
like I'll just fine just get it Wow you
don't have to know this kid to know that
he had ice cream for dinner a couple of
times but then to be filming it too she
filmed it I'm saying you know it's this
is generational man like this is [ __ ]
not only that's what that sixteen year
old that gave that little boy a tattoo
he had given a tattoo like he often
gives tattoos out of his home which is
very unsanitary oh yeah thief and he's
already had one of his clients get an
infection and she still let him in
that's crazy
I like clients of shitty artwork yeah I
like it they had clients yeah you know
right like who would go to this you know
where she [ __ ] up is if she was smart
about it she could have argued that it's
a part of her druid culture in that
they're supposed to tattoo people at
nine in the religion that she's a part
yes you know she could have gleaned like
oh you're [ __ ] disrespecting my
culture yeah but she let her
nine-year-old get a tattoo Shania be
that smart I know I'm just saying if you
wanted to beat the system yes if you
wanted to beat the system did you know
that there's a percentage of people in
Australia who register religiously as
Jedi because they're [ __ ] trolls when
I hear that and people like oh that's
crazy those people are insane I'm like
they're just funny people yeah just like
the spaghetti Pastafarian oh yeah yeah
the the speaking Flying Spaghetti
Monster thing I mean um I think it's
Luciferians or Satanists or one of them
they're like they parody that thing
they're not real devil worshippers but
like they do it to kind of scare
everybody
[Music]
[Music]